for days it's been the center of a
political crisis but now a very personal
one too
and coming to manston to locate his
eight-year-old nephew
an attempt to free him from the
overcrowded Immigration Center if
something have an emergency there if you
call 999 it doesn't matter where you are
yeah the help they will arrived there in
three minutes but this is no help this
is disaster look yeah no bets no fresh
water air no toilets No cameras nothing
zero
and from within the perimeter fence came
a desperate plea for help this letter
thrown in a bottle by a young girl
describing the conditions as prison and
claiming there are pregnant women and
sick detainees inside the site is still
at more than double capacity even after
hundreds of Asylum Seekers were bust out
it's unclear where to and unclear for
how long
of all the people who arrived in small
boats last year how many Asylum claims
have been processed
one prime minister
Mr Speaker we do need we do need
Mr Speaker not enough is the answer very
straightforwardly not enough and that's
what we're going to fix Mr Speaker he
says he says not enough you can say that
again
four percent four four percent we are
getting a grip of this system but this
is a serious and escalating problem
escalating because of what's happening
in places like this the seaside town of
Great Yarmouth it's one of several
places where the home office is trying
to house migrants in hotels but the
council here has taken legal action to
stop them citing a lack of dialogue yeah
what do you like in this seafront Cafe
though there was talk of little else I
know they have to go
somewhere in in one place the assignment
Seekers aren't going to be coming here
buying fish and chips and you know
anything else so for us it would just be
a lack of business that would probably
result in me losing my job as well the
hotel the Government tried to book has
similar concerns but is on the other
side of the debate its owner seeing
Asylum Seekers as his only source of
customers you can see my hotel is empty
at the moment yeah so I just want
business because you know we have been
hammered by kovid for two years and then
this year it was a sudden you know
inflation things are totally dead you
know you know many hotels are going
bussed you know many of the business in
this country so I don't want to be the
next victim but he says the council
didn't even consult him the fact it's a
conservative controlled Council here
that's opposing the government tells you
just how controversial this policy is
and they're not the only ones there are
at least three other local authorities
also taking legal action but that then
begs the question if not here then where
can these Asylum Seekers go
and it's a question that's only going to
get harder to answer as Asylum Seekers
continue to arrive Ivor Bennett Sky News
Great Yarmouth